what Tomales new president-elect
Alejandro giamatti on his fourth attempt
the man they called the eternal
candidate has finally won I'm very happy
happy and satisfied with the results
with the confidence of the Guatemalan
people but who is Gemma take a
conservative aims to resolve what polls
say a Guatemalans talked to concerns the
first security there's a lot of crime
and you're afraid to go out because
there are many thieves yamate plans to
get tough
bringing back the death penalty and
restricting rights for gang members in
jail and the second a lack of jobs that
least a quarter-mile is sending more
people to the u.s. border than any other
country it'll probably all the way the
problem is that since there's no work in
guatemala many people migrate and
sometimes it's said what happens to
those who die or get killed while
searching for a new future to help their
family diamantes promised to stop that
creating jobs by increasing tourism and
foreign investment to build what he
calls an economic wall it's going to be
tough inequalities deeply ingrained in a
country that's the biggest economy in
Central America but in which more than
half the population live in poverty
environment added to all this is an
unexpected challenge a deal just signed
by the outgoing president with the u.s.
it says that migrants crossing the
country mainly from Honduras and El
Salvador have to ask for asylum in
Guatemala rather than continue to the
States
if it's ratified it could mean tens of
thousands of new arrivals mr. Giamatti
doesn't want that deal but he may have
to take it the u.s. is threatening
tariffs if not
one other thing he doesn't want the
un-backed anti-corruption Commission
which hit graft in the business and
political elite hard he's shown no
interest in renewing its mandate that's
made him far from universally popular in
a country struggling with impunity
starting from January when he takes
office is four years to win over the
doubters John Holman Alderson